hi there and thanks so much for stopping
by today my name is bradley knapp with
ibm cloud and the question that i wanted
to go over with you guys today is what
is a network load balancer and so i want
you to imagine a scenario right
you have decided that you are going to
run a website and this website is going
to be immensely popular you need to
build it to scale to serve millions of
users all of whom are accessing it at
the same time so
imagine that single user and what is his
experience going to be right so you've
got your guy
he's out here and he's got a laptop
right and so on his laptop he wants to
open your awesome new website so he's
going to send that traffic out into the
internet
which we're going to put a little cloud
in there for the internet and then as it
transmits through the internet to the
actual servers where the data is hosted
it's going to get down here
and it's going to get to an application
server and that application server is
going to be what actually serves all of
the data back
via the internet to his laptop so that
he can view what's going on on your on
your website now
that's fine if you've just got one
person who accesses your website at a
time
what if you have 10 people at once well
that app server is probably going to be
fine to do that what if you have 10 000
people who are accessing it at once
and so that's when you get into this
interesting scenario
where you can saturate out this
application server and so if you think
about an infrastructure level definition
of an app server you can scale them up
to a certain size
but you've got limits in how big these
application servers can be so what do
you do all right well you need to scale
them out right instead of having one app
server you might have three or you might
have four or you might have five or you
might have 10 or you might have 10 000
you are going to horizontally scale
those application servers
so that you have enough to satisfy your
customer load
but
how do you know how much scaling you
need and more importantly how does this
guy with his laptop get to the
application server that he needs in
order to be successful
and the answer to that is in between
your customer
and all of your app servers
you are going to put a load balancer
what is a load balancer it's a hardware
device or it could be a software defined
device
and that load balancer is going to
intercept all of the traffic that's
coming in from the internet and it's
going to decide what goes to this server
what goes to this server what goes to
this server and so on and so forth
it's also going to provide and collect
information so your application servers
down here they can be talking to this
load balancer they can be saying hey i'm
only being used 20 of the time maybe you
don't need me right now and that load
balancer can then dynamically scale or
auto scale
and turn that application server off if
you don't need it helps drive down costs
likewise if all of your app servers are
checking in and they're saying hey i'm
super busy i'm running at 85 90
utilization it's time to bring in help
then that load balancer can hit that
auto scale service again and can say hey
look i need another one i need another
app server to try and decrease my load
and so when folks talk about cloud
native architectures this is a key
component the load balancer is a key
component because that load balancer is
going to assign out that traffic to all
of the different application servers and
then the app servers they're all going
to go down here right they're going to
talk to a common database tier because
you don't want to get into a goofy split
brain scenario with your database
but they're going to
get the data that they need and they're
going to serve that back up to the end
customer directly so
that's how you split up the data
that's how you serve it up but so now
that we're in load balancers we said
it's going to decide which application
server gets the traffic right how does
it decide what to do and so let's get
our three most common scenarios right so
we're gonna go over here
and we're gonna have scenario one
scenario two
and then scenario three
so scenario one
our load balancer right here right it's
got all its app servers
and
we're gonna call this one a relatively
dumb
load balancer right we don't need a lot
of complexity in it it's serving a
fairly basic purpose
and so it's going to use an algorithm
called round robin in order to sign
assign the traffic and so what does
round robin means it means that for the
first user that connects it's gonna send
that person to app server one for the
second person who connects it's gonna
send them to app server two the third
person who connects is gonna go to app
server three and then when a fourth one
comes in it's just going to start back
over again round robin literally means
just going sequentially through it now
round robin is not a perfect scenario if
you have user sessions that last a long
time some people log in and run for five
minutes some people log in and run for
two hours your app servers can get out
of balance with one another
when you're using that round robin
scenario
and so then you need to think about
things like smart load balancing smart
load balancing is going to be our second
piece here right and this is an
application server load aware load
balancer so again just like before we've
got our load balancer here and we've got
our app servers
but
this scenario this smart load balancing
scenario
rather than the load balancer just
acting as king in directing what all
happens
the load balancer works in cooperation
with the application servers so the app
servers are constantly transmitting data
back and forth to that load balancer
letting them know
how busy it is
and that load balancer is then going to
make the decisions to send the incoming
connection so your guy over here
if he comes in
and he starts a user session that load
balancer is going to say look server 3
has the least load on it right now i'm
going to sign him over here
and it's constantly monitoring that now
obviously you're going to look at that
and you're going to say well why
wouldn't you always use this kind of
setup well it is more complex to get set
up initially right it takes more
configuration also the load balancer
software or the hardware device that you
use to set this kind of a scenario up it
is more expensive and so while
technologically it's probably always the
best choice for your specific scenario
it might not be
and then the third the third scenario
that we've got down here right so we've
got our load balancer and all of our app
servers
this is a scenario where you want a
little bit more control
than you do in just a straight round
robin but you don't want to go all the
way through the setup and config and
everything like that that you need with
it with a smart load balancing scenario
and so there are actually like nine
different algorithms that you can pick
from
that split the difference between these
two
uh the one that i'm going to use right
now as an example
is a random select right so the load
balancer rather than sequentially
working through application server one
two three one two three one two three
over and over again it's just going to
run a randomizing function and it's
going to decide that maybe the first two
go to one and the third connection goes
to two and connections four through six
are gonna go to three and so on and so
forth again it's just it's different
kinds of algorithms to decide where you
need to go where you need to send that
traffic
and if you want to get into specifics
there's tons of information out there be
happy to to share that with you let us
know in the comments if you want to know
specific advice
please feel free to reach out to anybody
in the channel or anybody at ibm we'll
be glad to help you design and architect
a load balancing solution that is going
to work to help you solve the needs of
your customers thank you so much for
stopping by the channel today if you
have any questions or comments please
feel free to share them with us below if
you enjoyed this video and you would
like to see more like it in the future
please do like the video and subscribe
to us so that we'll know to keep
creating for you